foreign
[Music]
the blue avatars that you see in the
movie weren't created in an instant they
were a result of a series of successes
and failures over a period of time here
we will discuss their Origins and the
five generations of avatars that are
Canon to the universe so let's get to it
these avatars even though they might
look almost exactly like a navi were
engineered by humans so that they would
have a way to communicate with the
indigenous cultures of that planet the
planet Moon of Pandora they in essence
are hybrids of humans and a navi the
fully grown Avatar is much closer in
appearance to the long limb Navi than to
a human they have all the essential
features including the tail movable ears
large eyes blue skin the neural cue and
the ability to metabolize fully with the
Ecology of the place but they also
differ as well in a few traits like
having five fingers and toes instead of
foe having eyebrows smaller eyes a
human-like musculature and more
let's look at their Origins and the
Prototype well in the early 22nd century
travel and first Contact was made with
life in Pandora the RDA needed to
collect and acquire information about
the Navies which was difficult because
the navi refused to communicate with
aliens this resulted in Project Avatar
In which genetic information acquired
from deceased Navi bodies including
biosamples were sent back to Earth and
investigated the first successful clone
of a navi was then developed in the RDA
Labs however synchronization with a
human mind was unsuccessful due to
physiological and neural system
differences this spot the notion of
fusing human DNA with a navi nvt and
this hybrid was given the name Avatar
after the Project's name it looked
completely human with a few Navi traits
and this was the first step after
cloning the Prototype of generation zero
now the first generation the Avatar
program is constantly improving on the
avatars themselves more advancements
were achieved with each successive
generation including physical aspects of
the avatars themselves the first
generation of avatars looked more like
humans than Navi however all of the
physical characteristics including
strength and radiation resistance were
present the first generation is also
noted as being very similar to the
Prototype that was constructed some
years prior but because the Prototype
shown that it could not live as long the
design Choice was made to introduce more
Navi nvt than human DNA they were also
the first ones to be created in the moon
of Pandora itself rather than on earth
like the previous one
the second generation of avatars
resembled the first generation perfectly
however the avatars health and
physicality were both improved giving
benefits such as immune system
strengthening and increased Vision
hearing and sense of smell the first
generation lacked these since they had
more human DNA than Navi nvt still
avatars displayed somewhat more
human-like body musculature and
structured than the navi and the Q of an
avatar started at the base of the skull
whereas the navi Q starts at the top of
the skull which is also just a minor
difference
the third generation now resembles more
Navi than humans and it is the final
generation a distinction that was
overlooked in this one was that this
generation of avatars is capable of
reproducing with each other and the
indigenous navis as well it is unknown
why this generation was able to achieve
this feat many people in the program
speculated that as technology improved
in generating avatars the navi nvt
became the dominant genes thus making
them able to do the deed this third
generation is also the first in which
avatars were created on the five-year
Journey from Earth to Pandora Engineers
have designed this generation of avatars
to be grown in route allowing them to
live longer than the previous ones while
also having all the necessary immunity
metabolic processes and all needed for
Pandora
then we have Generation 4 or The
Offspring hybrids which although are not
avatars since they have their own
Consciousness and were born from a navi
still have quite a few human traits as
they have a tiny bit of human DNA in
their cells these were the children of
Jake and natiri as well as the solo Kiri
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video and do hit the like button for
support as well as subscribe but most of
all smash the Bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam